um so first of all congratulations on
this show people
are loving this show the comments like
honestly people can't get enough which
must feel so good for you guys
stefania why do you think so many people
are connecting with this show
i think that people are connecting with
the show because it's so relevant to
what's happening now
and it was so bizarre because the comic
book was written in 2009
2008 2009 and the pilot was filmed right
before the pandemic
and so it's very eerie timing that you
know the show was filmed during this
crazy time in our world so i think
there's a lot of
familiarity to the story and then at the
same time there's so much
innocence and hope and light that
it's not just about a pandemic it's
about
change and and finding a new way
and and yeah you get to see it through
the eyes of a
10 year old which i think people
are are really connecting with because
you know it's so easy to just want to
give up during these dark times but when
you have that
hope it's exciting and and i feel like
yeah people are i mean the hybrids are
all so cute
and it's like a storybook but at the
same time
you have these really incredible themes
and dark themes
um so i think it's just this incredible
balance that the writers were able to
bring on the script and everybody that
was involved
everyone was so passionate and that
collective
work i think just i think the world is
also just being ready
you know the world is ready for
something light like this for
you know this is this is like light at
the end of the tunnel and we've all been
through so much
in our you know personal lives going
through covet and this pandemic and
there's so much
change as well you know i know that
stefania's character you know she places
like
young teenage with a with a with a cause
and
it's like almost like a political
activist and that's a lot of what's been
going on in our own world
so to be able to look at it from a
positive and optimistic perspective
and to see okay what have we learned
what can we let go of and how do we
start anew
i think the world was ready for a
message like that and
it's all it's really brought us all
together i feel you know look even
looking at the hybrids it's like what if
you know this a new a new species or
something would come along and here we
are
fighting each other rather than coming
together and taking care of our earth
and really
making a better making this a better
world for our children
who are the future uh what if we looked
at life like that and i think that's a
that's definitely a message and uh and
and a different way of looking at life
that sweet tooth
the show has really allowed us to get
into those types of conversations now
i completely agree i mean it's you know
sometimes a series takes like an episode
or two to get into but like right off
the bat
people are just hooked with this series
which is so amazing well speaking of
everybody involved obviously robert
downey jr is an executive producer on
this did you guys get to facetime him
i i didn't get to facetime robert downey
jr
but i think you know there's been so
much going on
with the show and christian who who
plays our he's our fearless leader he
plays gus
sweet tooth he has gotten a lot of
opportunities to to
to facetime with him and i think that is
where the core
of it all it all comes from but we have
all felt their support
him and his wife and i have all been
very aware that they've watched the
dailies on an everyday basis and how
pleased they are with everything
and that really motivated all of us you
know throughout you know being a part of
the film just to know that we're really
being backed by our producers
the way that he's been back in the show
has been really special
oh i love that you know obviously you
couldn't tell
you know with james brolin being the
narrator on this what he was going to
sound like in the impact he'd have on
the show until you watch this
series back but stefania how good is he
is the narrator
i love him as the narrator uh it's
almost like
it it's so comforting to have somebody
on
your side because through the story
it's really intense and a lot happens
and there's so much going on but the
narrator is kind of your friend
taking you through and like holding your
hand
and i think he did an incredible job
yeah well i love both of you guys in
this the whole cast is so good and
i'm fingers crossed for season two okay
you know i'm not the only one saying
this
awesome
you